this is the scary thing if you look in a
culture such as Japan which has a
rapidly decreasing birth rate
in a level of technology that a Japan
has actually is more than the United
States you could be in a elevator five
floors down in a parking deck and still
get cell phone reception in Japan but
they utilize technology to the point
where you can be in Japan and they have
hug parlors because men might need
affection and then they just go get a
hug
to say that that will not be a reality
within our modern culture today within
America within North America within
Western cultures is not far outside the
reality and I think that's something
that has to be assessed